let's start today with Ron DeSantis now
if you listen to our episodes or watch
the videos a day or two later than we
publish them we may already know the
answer to the question of whether Ron
DeSantis will or will not enter the 2024
Republican primary race speculation is
that he is going to announce if he will
announce as soon as this week but
extraordinarily fascinating is a new
report from The New York Times that
privately one of the ways that Ron
DeSantis has been trying to convince
major Republican donors to support him
instead of Donald Trump is by telling
the donors that Trump cannot win in
2024. now the interesting thing about
this is that in a strictly mathematical
sense based on polling DeSantis may
actually be making the most fact-based
argument that could be made about why
someone would choose DeSantis over Trump
in the Republican primary Eva even if
they are sort of Mega people and we're
going to look at that polling but it's
not wrong in a strictly factual sense
for DeSantis to be making this argument
but is this the way to project strength
to those who are saying well we've got
the former president Trump but maybe I
want something different so I could
support someone else does IT project
strength for desantis's case to be
Trump can't win so give me money instead
we look at this report Biden and me
DeSantis privately tells donors Trump
can't win Governor Ron DeSantis of
Florida all but declared his
presidential candidacy Thursday
afternoon telling donors and supporters
on a call that only three credible
candidates were in the race and that
only he would be able to win both the
Republican primary and the general
election quote you have basically three
people at this point that are credible
in this whole thing
uh Biden Trump and me and I think of
those three two have a chance to get
elected President Biden and Me based on
all the data in the swing states which
is not great for the former president
and probably insurmountable because
people aren't going to change their view
of him
this is correct the it it's such a
unique situation in which we find
ourselves right now I believe that
DeSantis is right when we look at new
and recent polling of different kinds
um you see that uh let's see which of
these are the most relevant to what
we're talking about there's a Harris X
poll which is done in partnership with
Harvard if you look at that one Biden
DeSantis are even but Biden is losing to
Trump by seven that's an outlier in
which Trump does better against Biden
than DeSantis but you look at most
polling and Biden does better against
Trump than he does against Ron DeSantis
for example you have uh Biden actually
you know in reese is this turning around
I'm now looking at the last I looked at
this was Friday there's a bunch of new
polling which actually says that Biden
is doing better against the scientists
than Trump so if the polling is turning
around maybe this is wrong but
historically uh Biden has done better
against Trump than DeSantis so let's
imagine that these last couple of polls
uh are outliers and don't represent the
broader picture DeSantis isn't wrong in
saying that if we were to get to a
general election match-up I do better
against Biden than Trump let's imagine
that that's true but this is a very weak
case to be making this is a sign of
desantis's insecurity and fear of trump
which is very clear which is to skip and
just say if we get to November I do
better
whether or not that's true because
DeSantis doesn't really know how to run
against Trump so these are the sorts of
things he's relegated to telling donors
well it's not about I'm going to do
better with X group in the South or
whatever the case may be it's Trump
can't actually win and I could so the
idea is undermine Trump in front of
donors behind closed doors appeal to the
donors and say to them you need a more
viable alternative and I guess it's me I
don't know that this is an effective
strategy to win the Republican primary
that's the critical thing to understand
even if DeSantis is right he does better
against Biden than Trump or if he's
wrong
this is not a strategy that is going to
propel DeSantis to winning the
Republican nomination which he has to do
first because when you look at the
strategy of DeSantis on policy on the
one hand during Trump's presidency
DeSantis was a major Trump brown-noser
and sycophant DeSantis echoed some of
Trump's lies about the election
DeSantis echoed much of what Trump was
saying about covet even though now in
retrospect they're pretending that they
were really far apart on covid but you
look at immigration you look at voting
rights Banning books that criticize
Trump from public schools you look at
all these things this long period of
time they were in lockstep and in
retrospect now both are drawing
distinctions and trying to criticize the
other as saying they went the wrong way
I now represent the heart of the
Republican party that doesn't seem like
it's going to convince Mega people to
abandon Trump and support DeSantis and
that's what this is all about I'm
getting so wound up I just punched my
microphone I apologize to people
listening with headphones at the end of
the day this is a math or maths problem
uh DeSantis even if he gets all of the
current non-trump vote
cannot get to 50 in the Republican
primary and so when you hear desantis's
behind closed doors telling donors Trump
can't actually beat Biden or whatever
the case may be the donors if they're at
all connected to reality should be
looking at DeSantis and saying listen
Ron meatball whatever they call them at
this point even if we believe you that
you're the guy that can beat Biden
this isn't going to help you beat Trump
who already has 55 56 57 percent of the
primary what exactly are you going to do
to turn Trump voters to your side and
DeSantis has no answer to that
whatsoever so DeSantis is doing the
thing that oftentimes primary candidates
who will lose are going to do look at
Nikki Haley Nikki Haley instead of going
after Trump other than to say I'm from a
different generation basically I'm
younger and I'm a woman Nikki Haley has
been mostly criticizing Joe Biden that's
a loser's strategy you're not explaining
how you win the primary when you just
say here are all the problems with Joe
Biden Trump spends all day criticizing
Joe Biden it's not going to convince
Republican voters so I'm as curious as
anybody else to see what happens if and
when DeSantis enters this race that
maybe today that maybe tomorrow or he
may say if if better judgment gets to
him I can't win this thing I'm going to
wait until 2028. I I struggled to
imagine DeSantis gets away from polling
20 and saying maybe I could double it
maybe I could triple it so we will know
much more very soon but in the meantime
DeSantis having major problems in the
State of Florida and I want to talk
about that next
one of our sponsors today is fume not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad part
from your habit fume is an Innovative
award-winning device that does exactly
that fume is not electronic there's no
Vapor or harmful chemicals fume is just
a delicious flavored air that makes
replacing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable Parts which
is great for fidgeting which can be
great for people breaking bad habits
look at what people online are saying
they weren't sure what to expect but
ended up loving the taste and the feel
stopping is something lots of people put
off because it's difficult to do but
switching to fume is easy and enjoyable
there's no reason that you can't be the
next fume success story head on over to
try fumed dot com and use the code
Pacman to save 10 percent when you get
the journey pack which comes with the
device and three flavors the link is
down below